foreign
[Music]
welcome to another speedrun game people
of YouTube so we're black against table
flippers 2000 we have a Sicilian
and
let's see how this one goes again going
for the accelerated dragon
and we haven't faced D4 all that many
times we Face virtually everything under
the sun we Face Bishop C4
Bishop B5 the russellimo which is more
popular than I realized I didn't realize
that this move is popular uh below let's
say the nmfm level and yet
I think we've almost faced it more
frequently
than the open Sicilian with D4 which
we've only had like once in the entire
speed run so we Face the rosalimo I
think four or five times throughout the
various speedruns and I've advocated the
same line every time and this line is
consistent with uh The Accelerated
Dragon just like against the closed
Sicilian which is Knight C3 the way that
you choose a lion against the rosalimos
you ask yourself well what do I play
against the close against the open
Sicilian and if you're a taimanov player
then you play E6 here if you're an
accelerated Dragon player then it makes
sense to still play G6 because a lot of
the ideas and structures are pretty
consistent with what you would get in an
accelerated Dragon obviously because
you're basically playing the same type
of setup regardless of what white does
Knight C3 so the main line here is um
Bishop takes C6 generally white trades
on C6 and damages Black's Pawn structure
we get the bishop pair and I'll kind of
remind you of of how the game tends to
go after the game Knight C3 is not a bad
move but it's not a particularly special
move either it doesn't have that much
independent value because likely white
will take on C6 on the next move
our approach does not change we play
Bishop G7
I am expecting Bishop takes Knight but
our opponent is kind of playing this
non-theoretically it's likely that he
doesn't really study the rosalimo he
just sort of decided to avoid Theory now
in this position there is a kind of
Crossroads between two different setups
the setups involve deciding where we
want to
where we want to put our Knight now the
obvious developing move is Knight F6 but
if you've watched some of my Sicilian
games you might be aware that there is
an alternate setup that I really like
and I've advocated for it previously
which I called a batmanic setup I mean I
don't call it that way I think that's
how it's commonly referred to and that's
where you fianchetto your King's Bishop
then you push your E Pawn either to E6
or even E5 and then the Knight is
deployed on E7 and that way you're
making little you know little Cubbies
for your minor pieces and they're not
stumbling over each other
of course the drawback of Knight F6 is
that it reduces the influence of the
bishop and it potentially walks into uh
the move E5 although that's not
dangerous right away because that pawn
is going to become more of a liability
than a strength
so the drawback of the move E5 is that
it creates a huge weakness on D5 but as
I've explained previously in these
particular Sicilian lines the weakness
of that square is not as big of a deal
as some people think it is and so E5 is
a viable continuation here but I want to
play it simple because our opponent is
not playing this theoretically I don't
want to waste too much time
you know deciding on
how we develop we're just going to play
this in in a very meat and potatoes kind
of fashion let's just go Knight F6 here
uh and see what our opponent is up to
yeah E6 E6 is also possible with the
idea 97 but there is a major attack I
would call it a tactical drawback of the
movie six so between E6 and E5 I would
choose E5 and I'll explain why after the
game okay so E5 is not dangerous almost
ever in the rosalima structure because
the Knight can jump out to G4 and
immediately hit the quality five three
different ways and that would
essentially Force white to take on C6
which is what we want we want the bishop
pair and then the Knight can drop back
to H6 so you shouldn't rush with the
move D6 here you should wait for white
to put his cards on the table if white
plays D3 then the situation changes
because then E5 becomes a more serious
positional threat
why do I say that well because if white
already has D3 included then after E5
Knight G4 white can solidify the pawn
with Bishop F4 and then white can
basically keep this Pawn on E5 alive and
then play H3 and white has managed to
get away with E5 without having to give
away the bishop pair and without having
to give away his light script Bishop now
Bishop F1 is a very passive move
now the thing is it's not like we're
winning after this move or we're much
better but our opponent is essentially
doing a whole lot of nothing
first he brought his Bishop out to B1
now he's deploying it back to the
initial Square
but our approach doesn't really change
we're basically playing this like an
accelerated Dragon we're making all the
standard moves and there's one more
standard move that we haven't yet made I
think some of you might be tempted to go
D5 here and try to grab more of the
center and I think D5 is a very
reasonable move maybe even the best move
maybe even the best move I think D5 is
the ambitious approach because it grabs
more of the center the more
sicilian-esque move here would of course
be to play D6 which completes the
accelerated Dragon setup it's largely a
matter of taste D5 versus D6 D5 is the
move I would play in a classical game to
try to punish white to the maximum but I
like to illustrate Sicilian ideas in the
speed run so here we're going to play a
little bit more modestly with D6
especially because our opponent is not
showing anything convincing so it's a
good idea to just give him a little bit
more rope
yeah so we have the the classic Dragon
setup we have all the all the standard
moves and now I would say we're moving
into the middle game even though it's
only move eight move eight
so what are the typical plans available
to Black in a position like this well
there is one stock plan that almost
always is implemented once you complete
your overall development and I should
point out that you don't really need to
bring this bishop out I think some
people would go Bishop D7 here just out
of principle because you want to
complete your development but because
the center is closed and because we have
great control over key Central squares
we don't have the need to bring this
bishop out and connect the rook and the
queen that doesn't really do anything
I think we should keep our Bishop on its
initial Square until a more suitable
Arrangement is found and the typical
plan that I'm talking about involves
expanding on the queen side it's a plan
of Queen side expansion now once I say
that you should already be thinking
about this particular sequence and this
sequence involves playing A6 and then
following up with B5 and once you do
that not only do you grab space on the
queen side and secure important squares
but also you create a very nice post for
the light squared Bishop you can then
fee and keto it to B7
so you're doing several things at once
by playing Asics it's a very low risk
higher reward move and already we're
starting to pose some early problems to
White
now of course white could play A4 and
prevent us from easily playing B5 but
that doesn't mean we abandon our idea
and the Very typical follow-up is for us
to play Rook B8
then we still aren't in a position where
we can play B5 because white has three
Defenders on that square but there are
ways around it we can for example even
bring our Queen up to A5 and that does
help us prepare B5
um so
the way you should think about this but
it's a very kind of low risk position
for both sides white is very solid and
so you shouldn't expect to win this
position quickly you shouldn't expect to
be winning on move 15 it's going to take
us a while to grind white down here and
we haven't had a lot of games like this
which is why I'm really really looking
forward to this but if you take care of
your fundamentals you optimize your
piece placement eventually something is
going to manifest itself the key thing
is that you don't want to rush with
anything in a position like this and a
good example of that I wouldn't rush
with B4 this is a move you can play
essentially whenever you want so I
wouldn't cash in my chips until a good
more opportune moment has occurred
especially because we have more
important things to do I think it's a
good idea to complete our development
and now a good square has been afforded
to our Bishop so let's go Bishop E7
complete our development and you might
say well is this really such a good
Square it doesn't it bite on granite
yeah it's not the best Square in the
world but you know the center is quite
likely to open at some point and then
this bishop could very well become a
monster I mean we could conceivably play
D5 uh White could get rid of the E4 Pawn
so this bishop I think might play an
important role a little bit further into
the future also White's Bishop its
counterpart is also terrible Queen D2
threatens Bishop H6 we've talked about
this what is the most effective way of
taking the sting out of Bishop H6 it is
to play rookie eight and I'm playing
this move quickly because I've already
pointed this out as a typical uh
defensive idea in all Dragon positions
and not just in the dragon in any
opening where you fianchetto your bishop
and you want to keep it there are some
situations where you don't mind the
bishop getting traded here obviously we
want to keep our Bishop the point is to
meet Bishop H6 with Bishop a change so
that you don't lose the exchange 92 okay
so our opponent continues to play in
this kind of weird style where none of
his moves are flat out mistakes because
White's position is still super solid
but our opponent is also not doing
anything terribly productive and giving
us a wide berth uh to do whatever it is
we want to do and there's many things
that we we can do we can play D5 here
and I actually really really like the
look of D5
just visually the move D5 appeals to me
a lot because it's it's logical and it's
a nice way of punishing white for
releasing their control over the D5
Square
so we need to do a little bit of
calculation when we play D5 obviously we
potentially give up the C5 Pawn but
after Bishop takes C5 D take C4 it's
very clear that the center opening up is
in our favor that should be a high level
statement that you do not find to be
controversial in the least
because our pieces are much more active
we have a lot more space the only other
thing that we need to consider and I'm
going to play D5 in the interest of time
the only other thing that you would have
to consider is E5 and after E5 black has
a choice we can simply drop our Knight
back to D7 and then the E5 Pawn is going
to be lost
alternatively
we can
push D4 which is another typical pattern
that you should be aware of
counter-attacking White's bishop and
that may seem to lead to complications
but in fact it's quite easy to calculate
them
so after E5 D4
um white can take the Knight then black
takes the bishop and hits the queen
so white will not be able to take on G7
white will have to recapture on E3 now
the line goes on if we take the pawn on
F6 white takes on C5 and at the end of
the line we can snap up the pawn on B2
and we emerge with a bishop pair and
white has a completely ruined queen size
structure so I'll show this line after
the game for some reason I think our
opponent's not going to play E5 I'm
expecting e takes D5
but we'll see we'll see
so what are we threatening here what is
actually our next move our next move is
not D4
this is a common misconceptor we're not
playing D5 to lock up the center again
because the white Bishop has plenty of
spots on this diagonal we're not in a
position where we can try to trap that
Bishop unless of course white plays
Knight F4 then everything changes and D4
wins the game
the point is we just want to play D E
like we just want to freaking take the
pawn
and we're also positionally just
improving or grabbing space and creating
pressure in the center
so black is better
you know we're starting to convert our
positional Advantage into something a
little bit more concrete
so you should understand exactly what
happens if white plays Bishop takes Pawn
then we play Pawn takes pawn pawn takes
pawn and Knight takes spawn okay so
white does play E5 okay fine so we need
to decide between the simple Knight D7
going after the pawn that's the sort of
materialistic approach
now who can tell me and if you're
watching on YouTube you should be aware
of this too what move has to be properly
considered after Knight D7 this move
it appears quite scary
at the very least we should be aware of
whether it's worth refraining from
Knight D7 because of this move I'm
talking about E6 another typical idea
essentially throwing away the pawn but
ruining Black's Pawn structure on the
queen on the king side
and if you visualize this line Knight D7
E6 F take C6 white can jump into G5 with
the Knight and hit that pawn on E6 and
it turns out that that pawn on E6 is not
so easy to defend because if you drop
the knight from D7 back to f8 not only
is that passive but it hits it gives up
the C5 Pawn which is a key linchpin of
our entire Queen side operation so it
might be worth not allowing that at all
and just going D4 and saying to heck
with it
so D4 very tempting I have should have I
have to think about this for a second
I like the look of D4 of course D4 gives
up the E4 Square so it's got its own
drawbacks let me think about this Knight
D7 E6
F take C6 Knight G5
we could play E5 in that position but
then we'd have to be okay to part ways
with our dark squared Bishop which I
actually think we are in that particular
instance no I think it's not scary
I'm starting to err on the side of
thinking that it's not scary
although it's a
it's not an easy position to evaluate
I'll put it that way
okay let's take the plunge and go Knight
D7
I'm excited for some tactics
I want a little bit of action in this
position
so we're threatening the pawn
and we're threatening to take it
specifically with the c Knight
why because the denite is guarding the
C5 Pawn you should notice that right
it's guarding the pawn so what are we
threatening we're threatening Knight C
take C5 Knight takes C5 and then Bishop
takes C5 in order to keep this Knight
such that it defends C5
so white can play D4 I think some of you
might be expecting this move but after
D4 we play C takes D4 and again this
Pawn loses its supporter and then we
don't even have to worry about taking
with this Knight we can take with any
Knight because we've gotten rid of our C
Pawn
so that's easy to calculate to E6 of
course I mean the 2000 rated player
should see this kind of thing
and Knight G5 very good
okay
so we've got a choice here it's not our
move is not forced
what does our choice consist of well we
have a couple of creative ways of
defending this Pawn first of all we can
just push it we can just play E5
now the positional drawback of playing
E5 is that White's Knight can still sink
its teeth into E6 then we play for
example Queen B6 and then white
eliminates our dark squared bishop and
he does it with the Knight so that white
ends up with an uncontested dark squared
bishop and our King is pretty severely
weakened on the flip side we get a
massive Pawn Center we literally get
four pawns on the fifth rank as well as
an extra pawn and White's position is
still very passive so white doesn't have
the Machinery to really take advantage
of our King weakness that fast and we
can take the next couple of moves to
consolidate so that's one option
the other option is to play D4
send the bishop over to F4 and then push
E5 or actually drop back to f8 and this
is what we're going to do because this
involves
not giving up our dark spread Bishop
and that's one of the underlying themes
of this entire opening is if you can
avoid it you should try to keep this
bishop alive so look at what we just did
Knight f8 in this position would have
run into Bishop takes C5 we pushed D4
first which positionally is crappy
because it creates a hole on e4 and it
closes down the diagonal for the bishop
but a pawn is a pawn and you can't have
everything right you sometimes need to
make some concessions in order to get
things to work in your position
now what do we do well what does white
want probably white wants white has just
vacated the F4 Square I'm assuming that
white wants to jump into F4 with the
Knight so let's play simply
prophylactically with E5
let's play prophylactic chess let's push
the pawn up to E5 taking away the F4
square and restricting this Knight
Knight G3 suddenly our opponent has
started to play very fast and very well
I should say very well
okay
so let's think about this
um white wants to go Knight E4 this is a
rather problematic square that I've
given that I've given White
so we need creative ways
of fighting White's control over the
center
okay here's what I want to do
so why is Knight E4 an annoying move
well it's an annoying move because the
C5 Pawn is a weakness and it's a
weakness because it can't be protected
by any other pawns so if a pawn can't be
protected by any other pawns then it
should probably be protected by some
other pieces so you might say well let's
bring our Queen up to D5 but Queen D5 I
don't like because it potentially runs
into this move C4 and I'll talk more
about this particular move after the
game in the interest of time I'm just
going to play the moves I want to play
and then I'll explain them later let's
go Rook C8
I say Rook CA why are we putting the
rook in a closed file well the idea here
is completely defensive I am trying to
take the sting out of the move Knight E4
and what is it that I want to do after
Knight E4 well I want to move this
Knight somewhere we'll talk about where
we'll cross that bridge when we get
there
and then of course The Rook defends the
C pawn and The Rook on C8 is quite safe
it's hard to dislodge this Rook from the
C file
now we should start thinking about where
we actually want to move this Knight if
white plays Knight E4 because I'm fully
expecting this move
so Tactics come into play here right the
position is now a lot more tense than it
was a couple moves ago so we should be
alert to the possibility of tactics and
that possibility arises if we play
Knight before which perhaps you could be
tempted to do because it's the only
non-retreating move and Knight A5 puts
the Knight on the side of the board so I
don't like that at all the problem with
Knight before is that white can still
take on C5
and that's an easy tactic to calculate
Rook takes C5 Queen takes B4 and who can
tell me in that resulting position what
happens if we take the pawn on C2
so the line goes 94 Knight B4 Knight
takes C5 Rook takes C5 Queen takes B4
Rook takes C2 restoring the extra Pawn
but white wins The Rook with Queen to B3
check and that's something that we
should be very alert to because we don't
have an F Pawn anymore so we should be
alert to all tactics that are
that are generated on the a2ga diagonal
now in that final position there is also
the move Queen to D5 but the G2 Pawn is
protected by White's Bishop so you can
basically rule out any ideas connected
with some Checkmate on G2 as long as the
bishop sits on F1
okay so that leads us by process of
elimination to only one move if white
plays Knight E4 the only sensible move
to me I'm excluding Knight A7 because
that's just pathetic is actually Knight
back to B8
you might say well isn't that pathetic
as well well it's actually not because
from B8 the Knight has a very clear path
to rejoin Society it can go back around
to D7 and once it reaches D7 it already
is fulfilling a pretty Central role it's
reinforcing the C5 Pawn it's reinforcing
the E5 pawn and it can move on
potentially to F6 in order to contest
White's own Knight on e4
so that is a classic Frankfurt airport
idea by the way our opponent though is
taking
his sweet time
so I'm not all of this time was spent
deciding on a response to 94 it would be
consistent with this speeder and if our
opponent played something completely
different which is probably what's going
to happen
which is probably what's gonna happen
I I don't think they're considering F4
I don't think our opponent I mean F4 is
a very interesting idea whoa look at you
maybe you're my opponent
F4
okay what a move
I guess this is an instructive moment
for me because this move didn't occur to
me at all
this move didn't occur to me at all
now
um why
what is the point of this move let's get
our bearings and let's do it quickly
because we don't have much time so after
e takes F4 Queen takes F4 our opponent
is enamored with the prospect of putting
a queen on F7 and creating mate threats
but if we look carefully after EF Queen
takes F4 first of all our Pawn structure
has been improved we don't have doubled
pawns any longer so that's a good thing
it's a positive now can the square on F7
be protected by any piece well it
actually can we can drive Our Queen up
to D5 that protects the F7 Square now
what about the move C4 well C4 is not
dangerous in that position because we
can simply take on passant so I think we
can very safely play e takes F4
now there's no
necessity to play Queen Z5 I mean the
fact of the matter is Queen F7 check is
not a decisive threat because after we
shift our King over to h8 White doesn't
have like a very clear follow-up what
worries me in that position is the
prospect of White Moving the queen back
diagonally to B3 setting up the threat
of a smothered mate with Knight F7 and
in that position Knight F7 is very hard
to defend against because if we put the
Knight on E5 white will just snap it off
the board of The Rook takes C5 so
we need to bring the queen up to D5 we
need to be alert to the weaknesses in
our position and defend them Queen D5 is
Pretty Natural move
and should be should be understandable
to all of you
position is getting very tense
now while our opponent is thinking it's
very very hard to predict someone's
response in a position that's this
complex because one of the things that
defines complexity is the abundance of
options like white has a million moves
here there's Bishop E2 which I would be
very impressed with by the way uh trying
to improve the positioning of this
bishop there is I don't know like 94
there's you know whatever H4 so it's
hard it's it's hard to predict what what
White's gonna do
and in these types of situations it's
worth thinking more generally about what
you want to do and what our next move is
likely to be if white doesn't do
anything drastic so there are several
things that I would point out here the
first is that the queen and the Knight
are aligned so you should be aware out
of the corner of your eye of the
possibility of going Bishop H6 now the
point of this move would not be to win
the Knight because white can of course
then play H4 and because we don't have
an F Pawn we can't play F6 but if we
need to urgently eliminate this Knight
we can play Bishop H6 takes G5 and that
would perhaps lighten the load a little
bit on the king side
what else might we what other mental
notes might we want to make well another
mental note is that if this bishop moves
out of F1 let's say Bishop E2 is played
then we should reactivate the part of
your brain that deals with the
possibility of Checkmate on G2 it's like
the Jennifer Jennifer Aniston neuron but
I'll tell you after the game so that
very small slice of your Tactical brain
that's considering tactics related to
moving this Knight away or even in some
cases sacking on G2 and then delivering
a discovery
you should be considering those types of
things if white plays Bishop E2 if and
when
else well of course we have other levers
that we can pull in order to soften the
situation on the king side we can play
E5 we can even maybe play Bishop E5 in
some situations so we've got a lot of
options and white doesn't have a lot of
time because we're going to make one of
these moves and we're gonna beat back
White's pieces from their attacking
posts particularly the queen and we're
still up a pawn you should not forget
that
that was a lot of talking but I'm just
trying to lay out
I'm trying to explain this position in
more general terms so that you don't get
overwhelmed
now after Bishop E2 Knight B4 would be a
big mistake who can tell me why if
Bishop B2 is in fact played why would
Knight B4 totally reasonable move it
creates a double attack on the pawn on
G2 and on C2 but it's a Concrete mistake
because of Bishop F3 and that hits the
queen
that's the problem when your queen is
Right smack dab in the center it's
incredibly vulnerable so you have to be
very attentive to these types of things
and why is Bishop F3 so dangerous why
can't the queen in that position just
drop back to D7 well who can answer that
question in the chat
and this is on the topic of not
forgetting about old ideas this happens
so so often where you defend against
something and then you forget what you
defended against and so you just end up
allowing it yeah of course Queen F7
check is is what we defended against by
bringing the queen up to D5 okay let's
focus rookie 4 has been played
so again we have a lot of options here
so largely we're going to have to act
intuitively I really like the look
of Bishop H6 I like the idea of
eliminating this Knight moving it
removing it from the board
it's definitely going to make the attack
the defensive task a lot easier
especially because I just spotted a
really sexy tactic so without further
ado
we're going to start with Bishop H6
and we're going to force white to play
H4 now anytime you have this type of
situation it's a pin against the queen
in your mind you should understand that
the Knight is immobilized so the Knight
essentially can't move what tactical
move stems immediately from that
observation
Knight to E6 has to be considered
because if white takes with the Knight
then white loses the queen now after
Knight E6 white can take also with the
Rook on E6 and you might say I get it
then we take the Rook on E6 but that
would be wrong because then white takes
the queen and White's Knight is able to
recapture the bishop on F4 white gets
two pieces for a rook that's a miserable
position
so the key is after 96 Rook takes C6 to
First Take the Knight on G5 and we're
actually oh I've ordered mate
oh my gosh I blended made in two
I have 100 mate it's been a long day
it's been a long day
oh gosh let's see if our opponent finds
it he missed it oh my God
oh my God this is gonna this is gonna be
the most viewed YouTube video I can
guarantee you this is gonna be the most
viewed of the YouTube speedrun videos I
promise you
I promise you this will be this will
have like 500 000 views this will be
Levy type numbers
oh my gosh I completely forgot and and
the hilarious thing the funniest thing
is that I literally just talked about
this where you forgot why you played a
certain move I just didn't see that it
it cut the contact between the queen and
the square and F7 it is 4 AM to my in my
defense you two people before you burn
me at the stake okay you cannot script
this we dodged a bullet let's continue
playing we still have to win this game
we still have to win this game and this
just tells you that everyone's human
like this happens
some of these blunders are inevitable
especially in very complicated positions
of course what I should have done is
taken the Knight first and then gone 96.
what's hilarious is the moment the piece
is released you immediately see like you
immediately see it okay let's focus
here we don't actually have to remove
our Bishop from the board we can take on
G5 with the Knight
now what do we want to take on G5 with
well taking with the queen is good
because it offers the queen trade what I
don't like is giving white this extra
check on E6
giving white this extra check on E6
um so I think that we should actually
take it with a bishop well at least we
know our opponent isn't cheating
beyond a shadow of doubt
oh my gosh I cannot believe I just did
that
I didn't mean it didn't even occur to me
that this could possibly be allowing
anything other than Rook 66 this is a
classic classic example of tunnel vision
in its purest form where you're so
fixated on calculating something that
you simply do not ask yourself what are
the other possibilities
so it's a good it's a good lesson
and it happens at all levels obviously
Bishop E3 check obviously is uh
pretty much
um automatic here I think just stick the
bishop on an outpost and cut the contact
between the Rooks now let's finish it
off let's not give our opponent any
other chances
um
what should we do
well we have two extra pawns we can take
a third one on A2 and I don't think
there's anything directly wrong with
Queen takes A2 but I really don't like
the look of moving Our Queen away from
the center
the way that you win these types of
positions is you you make like
incremental improvements people run into
trouble when they try to win in one move
so you look at your position say okay
well what aspects can I improve just a
little bit and before you know it you
have some sort of winning idea so one
thing that we can improve is the
placement of this Rook like this Rook on
E8 what is it doing well it used to be
defending the E7 Pawn but now the Knight
is doing that and the Knight is doing a
perfectly serviceable job of Defending
that pawn so let's reposition The Rook
onto a clearly better Square onto f8
what is it doing here well it's not an
open file it can potentially infiltrate
to the second Rank and there are some
tactics by the way if White's Rook moves
away from E4 you can Envision some
tactics where you sack The Rook on F1 re
forcing white to relinquish their
defensive G2 then you move this Knight
away and you have some sort of mating
idea on G2 this type of
sort of General observation making is
super important if you want to see
complicated tactics because sometimes
they occur to you automatically without
you even realizing why something
occurred to you but mostly that happens
to more experienced players if you're
newer to chess you have to manually make
some of these observations
that was crazy I wonder if our opponent
ignorance is bliss in these kinds of
situations
if you realize that you blundered Maiden
two or you missed it you can't play
chess anymore like you literally and
we've all been there
the realization that you could have won
the game like 10 moves ago it's one of
the most excruciating feelings that you
can possibly have during a game okay C4
is an interesting move but it doesn't
accomplish much anymore
so do we take on passant well no because
our Bishop is now on E3 we need our Pawn
on D4 we need the services of this Pawn
to protect the bishop so obviously we
want to play BC
now why do we even want to play BC
because now we have a protected passer
on D4 and now the Rook on e4 is even
more poorly defended but our Queen is
attacked we gotta move it where do we
move it well we use process of
elimination there's a couple of good
squares as I pointed out earlier I
really do not want to allow if possible
the check on E6
so Queen G5 here is a decent move but it
allows that check
Queen D6 walks into a potential
Discovery so really there's only one
safe square and that's F7 I really like
Queen F7 because it also brings the
queen back onto an open file and it
creates a little bit of tension against
this bishop and if the bishop is to move
then we can move our Knight away
discovering an attack on The Rook so
that's the third benefit of the move
Queen F7 which is that it opens up a an
x-ray between blacks Bishop R bishop and
White's Rook on e4 which we can
immediately exploit with the move Knight
to B4 which we're gonna play
let's not hang mate again don't worry
once per game is enough God YouTube is
gonna have a field day I I'm already
like smelling it I think there's going
to be a Reddit post I I honestly can't
believe that our opponent missed it this
is you can't miss stuff like that
I guess it might also be Trust
like sometimes you don't even like think
that something like that could be missed
and my my name is in the profile
okay so obviously we I think we can just
take the Rook
I don't see why not
I have a lot of things to say about
reacting to these types of blunders and
you know how we can use that for
learning so I'll wait until after the
game Let's actually finish it off
yes of course E5 I'll talk about E5 I
still don't think E5 was perfect I think
Bishop I think what I did was good I
just should have taken the Knight first
but we'll check with the engine we'll
check what the best move was
now we're up in exchange the bishop on
D3 is hanging and we've got a whole host
of tactical options at our disposal if
white recaptures on E3 then many of you
are noticing Bishop takes G2 check King
takes G2 and queen to F2 King H3 Queen
takes C3
now does that win the game on the spot
it does of course when the queen moves
out of F7 you have to make sure that
there are no annoying checks or
sacrifices in the final position and in
fact there kind of is so if you
calculate this line right takes takes
Queen F2 King H3 Queen takes E3 last
question to the chat what move has to be
considered in that final position that
move has to be accurately calculated
because it's annoying yeah Bishop takes
G6 is annoying there and I wouldn't even
allow it honestly if I were playing like
a Russian Schoolboy given what I missed
earlier this game I would consider just
playing Knight takes D3 simple chess
also you can consider Queen F2 here but
Queen F2 here wait actually Queen F2
here might be the best move let me think
about this for a second the immediate
Queen F2 is what I'm talking about not
Bishop takes G2 Queen F2 the immediate
Queen F2 why because we're threatening
Checkmate on G2
so I actually think that Queen F2 wins
the game Queen E6 check Rook F7
but I'm not gonna bother I'm not gonna
bother because we have 40 seconds and
there's no need for that and again you
can play Queen F2 and you can start
calculating variations is this made is
this not made I actually think it might
be mate
so we might play it but the simple Rook
C to d8 also wins the game this is
really what I want to hammer home
okay let's go Queen F2
yeah let's go Queen F2
because you know I'm a professional but
what I want to point out is that you
don't always need to win these types of
positions
tactically or by delivering some sort of
flashy Checkmate or sacrifice you can
basically take all the pieces off the
board and then move like Rook C to d8
would be the move I would advocate for
someone who's less experienced and time
pressure to play because it reduces the
chance of a last second blunder and it
essentially forces The Rook trade
because if white declines the trade then
our Rook would swing over to D2 and the
pressure on G2 would be decisive
now this is an easy position to play so
I'm not worried about the clock
there is increment it's 15 plus 10. it's
15 plus 10.
yeah losing on time would be a fitting
end to what has been a pretty pathetic
display I'll talk a little bit about you
know what I found coaching
players and and their attitude toward
blunders
because I think a lot of people their
first reaction to a blender like this is
embarrassment and that's what I used to
feel when I was newer to chess but as
I've gotten more experience and more
confident in my skill I know that this
is an anomaly so I don't feel
embarrassed anymore I just I'm peeved
I'm annoyed like this shouldn't happen
but I'm human and it's 4am and I've been
playing Blitz for 10 hours today
uh so
it does happen
and I think it's particularly important
for newer players not to feel that
embarrassment when you blunder something
like this because now you see that it
happens to absolutely everybody and
that's not just a cliche phrase oh it
happens to everybody
like because you might think no it
doesn't like yes it does it actually
does even world champions blunder Maiden
2 made in three hang their Queens
and I've done lessons where all I do is
go through like the top 10 15 blunders
that occur at a super GM level
and there are a lot there are like
countless countless you know flat out
two move made three movement kramnik
misdom made in one uh in a match against
deep Fritz which was the top computer in
2007. that was really famous
and when that happened
when that happened there was this whole
buzz in the Chess World and I remember
thinking already back then why is this
such a big deal
right because from my perspective I
understood that these things they tend
to happen from time to time this was
kramnik's like allotment of blunders
right maybe once per decade this was it
2006 sorry this was it big deal it was
in time pressure he missed made in one
but of course people who are newer to
chess some of them at least have this
very black and white idea that once you
hit a certain level you are then immune
to blunders like you can you physically
are incapable of committing basic
blunders or hanging pieces and that's so
so so not true
also you might be your perception might
be distorted because if you're a Hikaru
fan Hikaru blunders even less than the
average Super Jam like he almost never
blunders which is what makes him the
greatest Blitz player of all time
even other top Super gems particularly
in faster time controls they blunder a
lot more
okay so here's cram next blender we'll
just start with that then I need to use
the bathroom and then we'll uh so this
was the famous kramnik blunder remember
that this was back when computers the
strongest chess engines were
approximately equivalent in strength to
the strongest humans in that time it was
Vladimir kramnik so in this position
deep Fritz has just played Knight f8
taking the Rook this is a draw black has
only one move here which is to run away
with the King pretty self-heaven King
Jian and it's a draw kramnik plays Queen
E3 thinking that he's winning he gets up
to get a cup of coffee and it was famous
at the time that the operator of the
engine right the engine wasn't making
its own moves what you same setup in the
Deep lucasparov match where there would
be a person who would read out the
computer moves and actually make them on
the board even he saw that it was made
in one so he didn't even need deep Fritz
like he couldn't believe it he's like
what am I missing and obviously it was
nothing Queen H7 mate kramnik was
shocked but
it was like a huge thing and I was like
why is this such a big deal this is a
normal
thing that happens from time to time
very rarely but from time to time the
other blunder that I saw
live I was watching this game live
and this was a super GM game between uh
Ernesto and archiev or sorry it's yanba
Crow who I think most of you have heard
of and Ernesto and archive who is a
Russian 2700 to 2700 GMS playing a
classical tournament
playing a classical tournament in Baku
and I was watching this tournament live
online
and this game caught my eye because it
was a really really interesting game so
I started watching it
and there was video link so but Crow
sacrifices a bunch of pieces and he gets
eventually the Smoke Clears and he he
gets a slightly worse position but he
has serious compensation he's down in
exchange and in this position let's see
who can figure out what white played in
this position where do I play
and then I have one final story for you
yeah you played Queen E7
and he resigned without awaiting
blacksmith Anarchy it was shocked
obviously but Crow resigned immediately
this happened classical game plenty of
time on the clock 27.
so you might ask well what has been your
biggest blunder over the board luckily
I've not made any like blunders of this
magnitude since becoming like an I am
um I've hung pieces before but mostly
when I was like two thousand twenty one
hundred but the biggest blunder that
I've made is a GM was also a blunder
that went unpunished those of you who've
been watching my stream for a while you
probably know this game because I
brought this game up several times
throughout the speedruns to illustrate
the fact that top GMS are actually human
believe it or not
here is the game
here is the game and this this game is a
funny story associated with this is a a
game that I played against jacovenko who
at the time the game was played in 2015
was one of the top Russian GMS he was
2737 also the first Super GM that I beat
uh a year before this game was played
Okay so
I'm playing Black
against the Alchemy let me fast forward
to the critical moment so 20 moves in
this position is reached let's flip the
board because you'll face me this
position has reached this was a Catalan
it's a normal position white is slightly
better my opponent is trying to double
Rooks on the C file and put pressure on
this weak Pawn so I decided being the
genius that I am to chase the Knight out
of E5 and I followed Ben feingold's
advice and played F6 at this point
Vladimir fettisif was a good friend of
mine and also a GM he came up to the
board
and he was standing at the board and he
was like looking weirdly at me I could
sense that something was up because
we're really good friends like I can
read his body language
it was at that moment that I realized
what was going on
what did I miss first of all and if
you're watching on YouTube you should
pause and figure out how white punishes
this move
this is a very basic tactic for a 2600
to miss this is crazy
yeah it's Knight takes C6 and the game
is over here's how the line goes now it
doesn't matter if black takes with the
bishop or The Rook the upshot is the
same you have a trade on C6 and then
white recapture Z6 with check and wins
back the bishop with two extra pawns now
black is able to win one of those extra
pawns back with Queen takes D4 this may
seem promising but white can just move
the Rook up to A2 this position is
resignable because black is also going
to lose this A6 Pawn white is the bishop
pair the king is in shambles this is
like plus three or plus four
so what I decided to do was actually get
up from the board and shake hands with
feather save and pretend that nothing
was wrong and it worked when I sat back
down my opponent played Knight D3 27 37
Feet a misses Knight 66 and the game
ended in a draw I was able to hold this
position
true story classical game
so the first and foremost the lesson of
this game not trying to justify the
blunder the blunder was horrible is
unacceptable I should have been punished
for it I apologize for it
um but to those people who who are now
thinking oh this guy is just another
human everybody's like that and you
shouldn't think of top GMS as gods in
the first place and as a commentator it
does sometimes tick me off when people
I realize it comes from inexperience but
when any mistake is committed or any
blunder is committed they're like well
this guy's washed up this guy doesn't
deserve to be at the super tournament
everybody blunders it's normal and the
last thing that you should feel after a
really bad blunder is embarrassment the
first thing that you should feel is okay
what happened why did I blunder how do I
avoid this the next time
and that particular process doesn't stop
even if you're a GM it's the same thing
that I'm gonna do but first we have the
first part of the game to look at before
we even get there so let's start the
analysis
the game started off as
a rosalimo
and rosalima by the way is a pretty you
should if you're watching on YouTube you
should look him up
marisolimo is a really interesting
character first name was Nicholas
I use a grand master who originally was
from France moved to New York like
started a chess store in the 50s was a
taxi driver super interesting story
so so you should definitely read about
him but the Russell limo obviously just
as popular at the top level as as D4 I
play this myself with white and uh you
can find a lot of my games in the
database
and so we respond with G6 Alternatives
include E6 which is the other main move
but recently there have been a couple of
Sidelines that have gained popularity
Magnus has played this move E5 which is
actually very hard to refute if you
don't know the theory beforehand but it
is a very dubious line uh even the move
G5 has uh has been played and this is a
very interesting line actually sacking
the pawn in order to gain the D4 Square
um Magnus has played this against me and
of course there's like the old move
which is D6 which transposes into a
position that arises via usually the
different move order D6 Bishop B5 check
this is the canal variation or the
Moscow and here there's Knight C6 but
according to Modern Theory white is
better here so without question I think
objectively best is to play G6
okay so Knight C3 is I would call this a
a third rate move
the main move the most popular move is
to play Bishop takes C6 this is kind of
the idea of Bishop B5
and forcing black to ruin the pawn
structure now if you've watched previous
speedrun games you know that my
recommendation is to take with the
d-pawn although BC is also a legitimate
move I think the previous game we had in
this line continued something like
castles which is the most popular move
um
or is it wait the most popular move here
might be don't remember if it's H3 or D3
Castle oftentimes like these moves are
interchangeable so let's say D3 Bishop
G7 and after castles here I advocate for
a setup that involves
building up essentially a reverse
marozzi bind so if I remember correctly
our previous Speed Run game actually
went E5
and here this makes a lot of sense
because the D5 square is protected by
this doubled Pawn on C6 shows you that
doubled pawns can actually be a great
positional asset
then what is the subsequent plan in this
position for black who can tell me first
of all where this Knight is developed
and what the typical plan is on the king
side and if you want more information on
this you can actually track down the
previous rosalimo game pretty early on
in the speed run around the time I was
1400.
thank you
so where does the Knight go first of all
and if you paid attention during the
game then you should already know the
answer to this so the Knight goes out to
E7
um for example let's say white plays
Knight C3 if white is not very accurate
here White's gonna be worse Knight goes
to E7 why why to E7 in order to vacate
the pass forward for the F Pawn and this
is the main idea in the rosalimo for
black of course if white plays Bishop E3
you have to defend the pawn
but if White's sort of Dilly dallies
with A3 here again you can play A5 and
you can prevent B4 typically white tries
to expand on the queen side either with
A3 V4 or sometimes you also see white
playing A4 A5 and trying to chip away at
the punching but if white plays A4 too
early then you're gonna lock up the
queen side and then when everything is
ready you're gonna start running your
king side pawns up the board King's
Indian style this is a very Kings Indian
style idea and that's why you see
inexperienced to our salimo players get
in so much trouble because it's hard for
white to figure out something productive
to do black in the meantime can
completes our development and when
everything is ready we start pushing F5
and of course we're already threatening
to play F4 and just run white off the
board with our pawns so
you should be aware of like the typical
plants here we were able to carry this
plan out in our previous Russell limo
game
now in terms of alternatives for white
I've never taken on C6 here I like the
delayed allop in russellimo which is C3
this is also Wesley's recommendation in
his E4 chessable course and I think C3
might be the most challenging of all of
White's lines actually it's more
accurate to start with castles Bishop G7
and now C3 apologies this particular
move order
and after wipe after black plays Knight
F6 which is exactly how black plays in
the alopin why does a cro why does a
choice there's E5 which I've always
played this is the old line Wesley's
recommendation is to delay E5 with
rookie one and then push D4
and then the theory goes D4 black trades
on D4 now Black's response here is very
typical and you should know this type of
idea if you're a sicilian player which
is to counter strike in the center with
D5
and after E5 the Knight moves into E4
and you get a very interesting very rich
line there's a lot of theory here I
won't delve into it you can do your own
investigating
but if you're a sicilian player for
black then you should definitely be well
versed in rosalima theory particularly
at a higher level okay so our opponent
plays a move that's really
non-theoretical it allows us to develop
our pieces optimally and without
obstruction and so the next oops sorry
so the next few moves I'll kind of go
without much annotation Ricky won
castles the one thing I'll point out is
that E5 is not very dangerous Knight G4
is a possibility here but even if you
drop the Knight back to E8 even if you
make this move which looks so passive
Black's position is super solid here
because the E5 Pawn is a serious
weakness
and yeah it's grabbing space but white
has to exert all these resources just to
keep this epon defended and if white
takes the Knight then after DC this
knight from E8 can seek uh greener
pastures through C7 it's a Frankfurt
airport Type move it can end up on D5 or
even it can move to D4 via E6 Black's
position here super super solid
no don't be afraid of these retreating
moves especially when they come in
answer to a move that threatens to
overextend your opponent or you can play
Knight G4
the problem is that after takes takes H3
you're gonna have to drop your knight
back anyway and I dislike this Square I
think it would be a better Square
so that's why E5 is not to be feared
our opponent played a very passive move
Bishop F1 and we decided on the more
sicilian-esque approach of course also
D5 would have been very good here as
well
okay so H3
and A6 so we have a question
um we have a question the reason my flag
is Canadian by the way is because I
started the speedrun in Toronto so I set
it to Canada in honor of that
so why D takes and not B takes so again
just to clarify in almost any roster
limo position B takes C6 capturing
toward the center is going to be
possible the general idea you take with
away from the center well there's two
things right first of all you open up
your Bishop second of all you increase
your contact with the center so the
queen is immediately now controlling the
D4 square and you do a better job in
this line of controlling the dark
squares in the center so it's a bit
easier to achieve the sort of optimal
setup if that makes sense
so I think it's just easier to play when
you take on C6 with a punt okay D6 H3
and we played A6 preparing Queen side
expansion our opponent plays D3 and
already after B5 Black's position is
preferable but it's not better I would
say preferable if you turn on the engine
it's still going to give approximate
equality but nobody in the right mind
would prefer to play White here
Bishop E3
okay so we decided to complete our
development with Bishop B7 Queen D2 and
of course rookie eight very important
tool in your toolkit in order to take
the sting out of the move Bishop H6 and
to meet it with Bishop h8 to meet it
with Bishop h8 since we're on this topic
I should point out that there are
situations particularly in the dragon in
the regular Dragon Sicilian where
uh where the presence of your dark squid
Bishop is so essential
is so essential that you actually
sacrifice I think I might have even
talked about this before you actually
sacrificed The Rook on f8 because you
want to keep your dark squared Bishop
particularly if White Castle's Queen
sided you see this sometimes so let me
see if I can really quickly find an
example of that just to give you a
better sense of the importance of
maintaining your Bishop in these types
of positions
this is just some like random uh
Ukrainian game
um this this stems from a Four Knights
uh fortnite's defense
so here you see black uh developing the
bishop to G7
White
Castle's Queen side white plays Bishop
H6 and fully expects to trade off this
bishop on G7 so what do you think
moyesenko very strong player now as
strong GM does what does black do in
this position
Bishop h8 Bishop h8 black preserves the
dark squared Bishop even at the cost of
the exchange which white takes
but black believes that his minor pieces
all of which are trained in some way at
the queen side coupled with the
influence of the semi-open B file will
afford him ample compensation for the
exchange and he's proven right now I
don't know what the engine evaluates
this as maybe white is better and white
tries to basically Force this bishop out
of commission but moisenko he builds up
the attack you know there's some trades
But ultimately blacks Bishops tear wide
apart white tries to attack in his own
right but eventually moisenko gets his
pieces to better squares Queen A6 and
now the sacrifices begin in this
position black already has a decisive
combination Bishop takes B3 followed by
Queen A3 with the Unstoppable Rook takes
B3 coming
and at the end of the whole line white
covers with the Knight here comes the
bishop so Black's decision to keep this
bishop alive was rewarded
and all hands on deck
and black wins the game
so what what is the takeaway from this
game it's that there are situations
where it's worth sacrificing in exchange
to keep that Bishop but in most
positions if you're a dragon player
accelerator Dragon player uh you should
really try whenever possible to keep
this bishop alive and you do that by
playing rookie eight of course here
sacrificing The Exchange makes no sense
since both sides are castled King side
okay so
this was one critical moment we have
other ways of playing here we don't have
to play D5 we can even play E5 like you
see sometimes this move played in order
to create a an outpost one could say on
D4 so E5 would be possible we could also
keep expanding on the queen side with B4
but we decided to play very concretely
with D5 so just to reiterate if Bishop
takes C5 then we take twice on e4 and
this is a great position for black the
pieces are just breathing here
white would have taken here we would
have recaptured with the queen of course
to keep the C5 Pawn protected and if
White's Knight swings back to C3 the
queen can drop back to D6 and we
maintain contact with the C5 Pawn this
is a great position black has a space
advantage in better placed pieces so I
think the way our opponent played was
definitely the sort of topical way to
play E5
and we drop our Knight back to D7 and E6
F takes E6 Knight G5 so now we really
the fun part of the game begins I
actually played the top engine moves
here
and the same principle if possible we'd
like to keep our Bishop alive
and we'd also like to do it without
giving away the C5 Pawn so this was out
of the question
this was my other candidate move 96
Queen B6 Knight G7 King G7 this is the
position that I had a hard time
evaluating I think black is probably
slightly better but it worries me that
this king is all alone permanently and
white has this uncontested control of
Key Dark squares around Black's King
making Black's position very hard to
play
the other annoying thing here is as
imposing as Black's Pawn Mass appears
it's actually very hard to set these
Pawns in motion this is important to
understand if you're a newer player
because you might get very easy well how
could it be that black has these pawns
and it's not I'm saying white is easier
to play because any time you play D4 you
create a massive hole on e4 which is
what happened in the game and once white
sticks a knight there well this Knight
is a monster now your pawns are not
going anywhere of course you cannot play
C4 because your Pawn is pinned so it
looks good but it's hard to get these
pawns rolling so what would I do here
with black well I'd probably move the
king back and I'd play this slowly but
white has many many ways to improve his
position as well so I didn't love this
and for that reason I decided to keep my
Bishop with D4 attacking the bishop and
dropping the Knight back to protect the
E6 Pawn
um
okay so Bishop drops back to H2 which I
thought was a good move uh vacating the
F4 Square for the Knight and retreating
moves often have this as the purpose
right the bishop drops back so it's
clear that the Knight wants to take The
Bishop's place and then the pressure on
E6 will be huge and so here I decided to
play E5 in order to cover the F4 Square
our opponent plays Knight G3 aiming for
E4 so far I think the play is very
reasonable we go Rook C8 I also like
this move
now I think F4 is a mistake even though
it could have lets it made into I think
it's a mistake I think White's pieces
are too passive to allow for the opening
of the center what should white have
done well I think white should have
stuck to his guns with Knight E4
and we would have made the Frankfurt
airport move Knight to B8 ultimately
trying to reroute this Knight to D7
now if you were playing white here I
think white has a very high level move
here
and it's instructive to try to find this
move I just checked it is the top engine
move
how does white improve his position
because the easy moves have been made
you've put the 994 what would you do
here with white pause the video if
you're watching on YouTube try to ask
yourself like how would you continue
improving and poking and prodding
you guys are monsters A4 is the best
move because you're trying to
essentially open another front
now you might say a big deal right black
can play B4 but if black plays before
then you're never going to be able to
exploit your advantage on the queen side
this is a horrible situation
funny side note in the old days about 10
15 years ago one of the reasons that
engines were really really bad at
playing the king's Indian defense for
white and you will find that Hikaru when
he played chess engines like 15 years
ago he would always play The King's
Indian with black and a huge reason was
that engines were very myopic so they
they weren't able to look as far ahead
as as modern engines are and what would
tend to happen if the engine would go
into the main line blah blah blah some
random variation
and the engine would essentially make a
move like A4 which is no human would
ever play this because this fully
relinquishes any attempt that white
could have at Queen side play and in the
king's Indian White has to play on the
queen side because white will never be
able to play B4 now and black completely
locks up to Queen side but the engine
wouldn't understand that it would over
prioritize things like a space advantage
or some other aspect of the position it
would not understand the concept of not
being able to make progress nowadays
engines never do that
so side note but this is the same type
of mistake that B4 would be but it might
be a necessity because if black does not
play B4
then White's gonna take on B5 and
White's going to have this open a file
to work with and Rook A7 already is an
annoying move although perhaps Queen B6
defends nicely
and now white could play Maybe rookie A1
and black could play Rook A8 and you
could get some trades and I think black
is better here white has insufficient
compensation but white can definitely
keep playing and keep pressuring
so remember these types of Moves Like A4
where if your opponent has a superiority
on one side of the board it doesn't mean
that you can't play on that side of the
board so the contrary moves like A4 are
often very very effective also remember
opening up the second side of the board
just because all of your other moves
have been on the king side and in the
center does it mean that you should
ignore the queen side you should play on
all sides of the board when possible
so A4 here would have been strong
position is about equal white plays F4
allowing us to undouble our pawns and
bring our Queen into the center so I
think everything I did here was perfect
Bishop H6 was also the top engine move
it's just in this position that the
crazy disaster happened 96 obvious
tunnel vision like the the reason for
this Wonder
is it really goes without saying common
situation where you spend so much effort
trying to calculate a particular line
that you forget to check for your
opponent's other moves you forget to
check for the drawback of your move and
that's exactly what happened here it
didn't even occur to me that the queen
could move because all I was thinking
about was Rook takes E6 and I was so
proud of seeing this move that I just
didn't come back to the initial position
which is what you have to do made into
was blundered
um if you fast forwarded the video the
tldr is that my opponent missed this
move this was an honest blunder it
wasn't scripted yes I would have put
this up on YouTube even if Queen F7 had
been played but crazy Mutual blindness
Queen G4
what should I have done instead of 96
well according to the engine the best
move is actually Knight to D7
why 1987 in order to open up the f8
square for The Rook which is a move that
we ended up playing later
you know the knight from C6 can jump
into E5 potentially and open up the
diagonal I mean black has a great
position the F7 square is safely
protected and C4 is never really a
problem here because you can always take
on Passat
now I should point out that earlier
earlier I pointed out that Queen D5 is
not as effective of a defensive move and
partially it is because of C4 because
here by taking on passant you're only
staving off
the move C4 but it's still possible also
I don't like Queen D5 because of this
bishop B2 Bishop F3 idea dislodging the
Queen the key difference is that if
white plays Bishop B2 here
white still threatens Bishop F3 but
black is in time essentially to chase
away White's pieces and now White's
pieces are stumbling over each other
because Bishop F3 is not possible
whereas Knight F3 takes away that Square
from the bishop and that means the queen
is safe again so notice how everything
is very concrete Queen T5 is bad in one
position it's good in another position
at this level you have to have that
concrete thinking in place otherwise if
you try to act on general principles
you're not going to go very far okay so
obviously we got ridiculously lucky and
the rest of the game I think is pretty
straightforward we planted our Bishop on
E3 white could have defended more
resiliently but at the end of the day
we're two pawns up I think C4 is
probably another mistake because it
gives us this Monster Pawn on on D4 and
this is another mistake I think after
night before it's already basically over
unless there are any questions I mean
everything we did was super
straightforward just to remind you you
can play it simple with Rook cd8
but Queen F2 led to resignation because
white is no good way to defend against
this
and this is just a meaningless check
because of Rook F7
can I say something about E5 but when
when when when when did I promise to
explain E5 like at what point
I'm not sure I remember that I I had
pointed out E5 but I don't remember when
E5 instead of the May planner oh oh oh
oh sorry sorry got it instead of the
blunder a lot of you were lobbying for
E5 and E5 is not a bad move
but I don't think it's a great move
either because white will reposition the
queen queen G4 and to me it's important
to keep the E5 Square open for a
potential night
right when you fill a square with a pawn
this Knight on C6 like hey what about me
I wanted to go to E5 does that make
sense also this queen is quite well
placed on G4 it's kind of out of the way
whereas on F4 it's susceptible to all
sorts of attacks like Rock Cafe
so I think E5 is a decent move but I
think Knight D7 the engine move is much
better or Bishop takes G5 and even
though I said yeah you don't want to
give away your fiancado Bishop you're
winning another Pawn here or you're
forcing the queen trade which is
obviously good for black because now you
don't have to worry about King safety
that much
oh yeah and then the other thing I
wanted to point out is in the opening
um some of you were lobbying for the
traditional botman Nick setup with E6
the reason I don't like this move and I
talked about this in an earlier Speed
Run white takes on C6 and you have to be
very careful about this situation if
black plays D6 everything is groovy but
before black pushes the d-pawn white can
shove this e-pawn down and cause major
problems on the dark squares we talked
about this because if you now play D6
well it's not the same because you're
left with these awful god-awful pawns on
the queen side and white as many ways to
attack them you know 94 the bishop could
come out to A3 this is all very well
known
if you ignore this Pawn then white will
stick a knight on e4 on there will be
hell to pay this is obvious of course
the way that I would deal with it is
probably F6 but again white could still
play 94 and Sack the pawn and stick a
knight here and you can see that this is
not what you want it's exactly not what
you want so the lesson is when you're
trying to implement the buff index setup
make sure that you're not allowing like
E5 in response to E6
and you're not allowing your opponent to
clamp down on these F6 and D6 first
that's why I always say you have to be
very careful about combining the moves
G6 and E6
okay any other questions what about
Knight H5 in the position he resigned in
on 9h5 you can just go Queen F1 check
and pick up the Rook you can just do
this and white has a check and you just
block the check and the game is over
yeah the bobbinix set up against the
Grand Prix is fantastic that's actually
the best way to play against the Grand
Prix according to most like uh modern
Theory it's the Bob Minix setup right
it's this whole like Bishop G7 and then
you play E6 and 97 this is the
traditional button next setup now here
white does have E5 but you can play D6
that's the chief difference
and here you maintain the Integrity of
your queen Side Pawn structure so that's
the key difference what about Queen H3
in the final position okay
so Queen H3
we would have played like Rook fd8 or
something and we're just up in exchange
there's no like one thing that happens
it's just white is overwhelmed white has
to trade Rooks here by the way
Queen E6 you can drop the queen back and
force the queen trade remember black and
white is just down and exchanging upon
so our opponent didn't see fit to
continue fighting
okay
um
how to get over rating anxiety well I'll
end with this and hopefully you found
the illustration of the blunder to be
Illuminating I know YouTube's comments
section is going to go crazy but I'm uh
you know it's not embarrassing I know it
happens so it it will it eventually was
bound to happen I don't think I'd
blundered like this at any point in any
of the speed runs ever so you know once
a thousand games it's going to happen
it's it'll happen again
um someone was asking how to get over
writing anxiety the only way is to play
because eventually you're just going to
feel that you're not in imminent danger
of dropping this is happening with me at
3200 I keep climbing back and at this
point I'm a little bit more comfortable
playing at that rating because I don't
feel like I'm about to drop it and then
never get back to it and you have to
remind yourself why you're playing in
the first place
all right
um hope you enjoyed the game this was
fun been a while since I've rated Hannah
let's read Hannah thank you not eBay and
everybody for the support hit the sub
button on YouTube if you like what I do
and you want to support me
um let's see if we can hit 500 000 by
the end of the year that's the goal
thank you everybody have a great one
I'll see you tomorrow I'll be streaming
later tonight
[Music]